I'm too literal literal guy you know
definitely hurt me in some social
interactions you know yeah I remember
just last week I was at a party girl
comes up and he goes are you gay I was
like no I'm not gay she goes whoa
another wrong being gay I'm like yeah I
know just saying I'm not she's like well
you're getting pretty defensive I'm like
well I'm not gay she's like well there's
nothing wrong with it I'm like I know
but I'm
not she wouldn't let it go eventually I
got annoyed I go what are you pregnant
she was like screw you I'm not pregnant
I was like whoa nothing wrong being
pregnant but we made up eventually we
we're cool now you know she was like I
should be honest with you I was uh I was
pregnant for about three months in
college and I was like oh that's when I
was
gay